o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
se você já parou para pensar que
histórias você conta da sua história o
que você não tá falando sobre você por
aí nada melhor do que começar com uma
história essa conversa avião marquei que
transportava pessoas de um continente
para ir na ilha mágica e viu pessoas de
diversos lugares para passar uma
temporada nessa Ilha mágica um certo dia
o Barqueiro apanhou uma senhora que ele
fez a seguinte pergunta por que eu como
são as pessoas da Ilha mágica e o
Barqueiro respondeu com uma outra
pergunta senhora como são as pessoas do
lugar onde a senhora mora e a senhora
respondeu as pessoas de onde eu moro
elas são insuportáveis eu não gosto
delas elas realmente me fazem muito mal
e eu estou querendo passar uma temporada
na ilha mágica justamente para me ver
livre delas
e o vaqueiro Então desse a senhora
Lamento muito mas você não vai gostar da
Ilha mágica passar dos dias uma outra
senhora entrou no barco para ir até a
ilha mágica e o Barqueiro fez a mesma
pergunta Vaqueiro como são as pessoas da
Ilha mágica e o Barqueiro então
respondeu hein a senhora como são as
pessoas do lugar onde a senhora mora
Oi e a senhora disse o vaqueiro as
pessoas são maravilhosas eu umas pessoas
de onde eu moro e realmente estou muito
satisfeita com a relação na relação com
elas eu vou passar uma temporada na ilha
mágica Mas eu já estou com saudade
dessas pessoas e aí o Barqueiro
respondeu a senhora pois você vai amar a
ilha mágica certamente será bem recebida
e bem-vinda eu quero te dizer com essa
história que nós refletimos
inconscientemente as nossas atitudes
através da história que contamos por
isso a nossa história não pode ser
entregue na mão de qualquer contador
você precisa ser um bom contador da sua
história eu vou usar a minha por nada a
minha história pra te ajudar a refletir
sobre a sua tudo começou quando eu
estava lá em Santarém no Oeste do Pará
fazendo o curso de pedagogia
e eu estava verdadeiramente perdida eu
não sabia o que fazer quando terminasse
o meu curso eu não sabia mesmo que nem
mesmo que escrever no meu TCC e eu já
estava no último semestre até que uma
noite uma professora chamada Gleice
goste me apresentou um tema que ia mudar
a minha maneira de pensar a educação e
mudar a minha vida eu estou falando do
ano de 2004 onde se tinha um paradigma
muito grande de que a educação está
relacionada unicamente ao espaço escolar
Mas eles que alguém usou a incluir na
grade do curso de pedagogia a disciplina
pedagogia em ambiente não escolar Eis
que alguém ousou abrir por uma sala de
aula e discutir esse tema com seus
alunos e esse que alguém comprou essa
ideia
e eu não sei de onde você está nesse
momento me ouvindo você pelo computador
ou tablet você pelo celular onde você já
parou para pensar como ver o seu maior
sonho naquela noite eu descobri o meu eu
me conectei tão fortemente com aquele
tema e eu pensei eu quero trabalhar com
a educação em ambientes não escolares eu
quero trabalhar com um pedagogo e uma
empresa contribuindo com as pessoas que
já estão no mercado de trabalho mas que
precisam se desenvolver melhor e eu
quero usar a pedagogia para isso como
fazer eu não tinha a menor ideia
se é certo que quando você tem um sonho
muito audacioso como esse afinal de
contas ser uma atuar com uma pedagoga
corporativa lá no interior do Pará é um
sonho dacioso você precisa acima de tudo
de atitude para tomar determinadas
decisões eu tinha consciência àquela
altura do campeonato que seria muito
muito desafio muito grande para mim
atuar em uma empresa como pedagoga
primeiro porque as próprias empresas
Elas não tinham ainda consciência da
importância de desenvolver o seu capital
intelectual
E além disso eu estava no interior do
Pará onde as coisas ainda eram mais
difíceis de acontecer tendo consciência
disso eu então tomei uma das decisões
mais audaciosas da minha vida eu deixei
tudo lá no interior do Pará eu deixei
minha família eu deixei meus amigos eu
deixei ao meu trabalho eu deixei a minha
vida lá e fui em busca de um sonho na
capital e o que o levei comigo eu levei
uma mala sem dinheiro e muitos muitos
sonhos a ideia de morar em Belém quando
chega chegando em Belém ainda era
seguinte eu distribuía currículo
conseguiria um trabalho em uma escola e
em seguida eu iria tentar uma vaga nas
empresas como pedagoga corporativa tava
tudo muito fácil mas não foi bem isso
que aconteceu
e eu distribuí muito currículos porém a
resposta era sempre a mesma eu não tinha
experiência na área escolar portanto eu
não conseguiria a vaga
e depois de muito muito tentados ouvir
então mudar de para seja era um dos
concursos públicos então eu decidi vou
estudar para um concurso público tinha o
celular vende esse celular e me
matriculei no concurso no cursinho para
fazer o concurso público primeiro dia de
aula é aula de português nos saudoso
Professor Augusto começou então a
explicar um tema e eu ali sentada na
primeira cadeira como a gente diz lá no
fará toda a pa Vila não tinha certeza
que eu queria né então sentei aqui na
primeira cadeira prestei atenção na aula
maravilhosa e o professor final me pegou
uma prova com 10 questões para quem
todos fossem e fizessem essas questões
essa prova era uma prova de último
concurso que tinha acabado de acontecer
de um tempo e eu então comecei a fazer a
prova Achei super fácil Nossa prova que
tá muito muito fácil só assim eu vou
conseguir passar rapidinho um
e quando ele começou a fazer a correção
da prova 10 questões e eu não acertei
nenhuma E para piorar ainda vi aquele
coleguinha que diz assim Bom pelo menos
eu acertei uma questão não tô fora da
jogada pior é aquele que Zerou a prova
não acertou nenhuma esse não passa nem
por milagre bom aquilo para mim foi um
banho de água fria eu saí de lá arrasada
e fui embora para casa andando um solo e
escaldante quase 40 graus lá em Belém e
eu fui pensando eu tinha duas
possibilidades a primeira eu desisti e
contar uma história de fracasso e a
segunda enfrentar tudo aquilo que tava
contra mim e ao final consegui contar
uma história de sucesso Naquela tarde
aquele sol do meio-dia eu decidi eu vou
em frente eu não vou voltar e contar uma
história de derrota eu vou seguir
e passei então a estudar 19 horas por
dia eu morava mal eu dormia mal com
minha mão eu não tinha lazer eu não
tinha dinheiro para comprar livros então
eu estudava muito em bibliotecas eu não
tentei muitos desafios mas nada daquilo
me fez desistir e finalmente no ano de
2007 eu consegui a minha primeira
aprovação no concurso público era para a
área da Educação mas era educação
escolar ainda não era o que eu queria eu
continuei a estudar e ficou ainda mais
difícil porque o meu tempo agora reduziu
E aí eu comecei a estudar de madrugada
continuava a sentir muito lazer
continuava sem ter muitas oportunidades
que eu deixei de fazer de sair de me
divertir para me dedicar um sonho
bom e depois muito vezes muitos acertos
e muitas lutas e finalmente 25 de
novembro de do ano de 2013 eu consegui a
minha provação aprovada em primeiro
lugar no concurso público com quatro
1997 inscritos para uma vaga e Adivinha
quem me ajudou a passar Sabe aquela
prova de português lá de trás que eu não
havia acertado nenhuma ela tava nesse
concurso também só que dessa vez é um 20
questões e ela critério de desempate e
das 20 questões eu acertei as diferentes
questões e aquela prova ela para mim ela
não foi só oportunidade tem passado no
concurso não ela foi para mim muito mais
aquele dia foi a realização de um sonho
que eu tinha de trabalhar com educação
corporativa
e há 13 anos eu atuo na área da Educação
há oito anos com a educação em ambientes
não escolares atualmente eu sou
servidora pública estou lotada na
Receita Federal mas já passei por órgãos
como a Snap a esaf Eu também sou
escritora de livros de metodologia de
treinamentos sou autora do livro design
de experiências de aprendizagem obra
essa que me fez refletir muito sobre a
minha história EA importância de um raio
e respeitaram a jornada e eu ainda sou
uma eterna Sonhadora inclusive está aqui
hoje falando nutex era um sonho que já
está realizado e o que que eu aprendi
com toda essa minha jornada o meu maior
aprendizado foi e nos tornamos tudo
aquilo que damos significado
o sistema é o significado que você dá
para sua história está conectado com
tristeza com angústia com fracasso você
não vai conseguir contar uma história
diferente você vai contar a história
conectadas com esses sentimentos mas se
o maior significado que você dá para as
suas histórias estão conectadas com
alegria com paz com amor e com sucesso
você vai contar histórias de sucesso
porque nós somos a história que contamos
da nossa história e é por isso que não
devemos nunca falar mal de nós mesmos e
eu estou aqui hoje para deixar essa
reflexão para você quem história você
quer contar sobre você de sucesso ou de
fracasso Pense nisso